MALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentlemen, please welcome
Brady Forrest.
BRADY FORREST: Hey there.
I'm Brady Forrest.
Thank you all for coming out.
This is the fourth or fifth
Ignited I/O and I think it's
the biggest one.
At least this year we won't be
hearing Jane's Addiction play
during our Ignite.
So thanks for coming out.
We've got 12 great speakers,
we're going to hear from a
number of Googlers.
And in case you've never
actually been to an Ignite
before, if you don't know what
Ignite is, it's a geek event
that has spread around
the world.
And it gives people a chance to
share their ideas and share
their passions in a highly
structured format that really
lets them to kind of bump up
against constraints and become
just a bit more creative in how
they present their ideas.
So each of these speakers gets
20 slides that auto-advance
every 15 seconds for a total
of just five minutes.
So they've had to really
condense their ideas down and
really be able to
drive them home.
And normally this is done
with beer at night.
We don't have that right now
but I think you'll still
really enjoy the show.
As I mentioned, we've got 11
great speakers and our first
one is here to talk
about hackathons.
Please welcome up Chiu-Ki.
CHIU-KI CHAN: Hello, my
name is Chiu-Ki Chan.
I'm here to tell you how
to win hackathons.
I went to my first hackathon
last year in
September and I won.
That app is actually an
app to teach people
how to write Chinese.
And it went so well
that I decided to
put it on the market.
How many of you here have
Android devices?
All of you?
Great.
Go download it.
I would really appreciate it.
So after Monkey Write I went on
to three other hackathons
and one demo.
So I figure that I'll share
my tips with you.
But first, what are
hackathons?
As this picture shows, just a
bunch of people in front of
computers, typing away, building
some software.
Usually there's a theme,
sometimes there are prizes.
There are three type
of hackathons,
in my mind, at least.
The first type is the business
model type, where not only do
you have to build software,
you also have to show how
you're going to make money.
The second type is the
complete opposite.
You are there to help
a nonprofit to
build a technical solution.
The third type, the type I love,
is the API hackathon,
where the sponsors will come
dangling lovely gadgets in
front of you so that you will
build something to the API.
And then they can showcase
how awesome the API is.
So the best way to think
of that is Iron Chef.
The API is your secret
ingredient and your job is to
cook up something that looks
good and tastes good.
Now, how does a hackathon
actually go?
Usually, it goes like this.
Come up with an idea, spend
all day hacking along,
building up your software, and
then you get onstage and you
present and you demo.
Now here comes the secret.
There are arrows on this slide,
but they're in the
wrong direction.
You need to work backwards.
You need to think about the demo
first, because that is
how you show how awesome
your software is.
You need to figure out how much
time you have and how
you're being judged.
Once you figure out that part
then you're ready to dazzle
your crowd.
From there work backwards.
Figure out how much
time you have.
Don't think of it as, oh, I
have a full-day hackathon.
Uh-uh-uh.
You need to eat, your
Wi-Fi will go down.
All kinds of stuff
will happen.
So count it in the
number of hours.
A full-day hackathon, I would
say, is a six-hour hackathon.
So know exactly how much time
you have and then budget
accordingly.
Don't think of too much
stuff to build.
So the first step is then you
need to study your secret
ingredient.
So in Iron Chef you
have your crab.
In our case we have APIs.
Figure out what they do, but
more importantly what you can
learn within that day and
build something with it.
Once you have those gathered up,
you are finally ready to
come up with your idea.
Now what makes a good hackathon
idea is something a
little bit not obvious.
What I mean by that, well, if
your idea is a dime a dozen,
everybody's implementing that,
you won't stand up in the
crowd, right?
But then if there's something
that is super out there, you
don't have time to
implement that.
You have a very short amount
of time during a hackathon.
Besides it's so complicated to
explain that there's no way
you can show at a demo
why it's a cool idea.
Once you have distilled a very
simple idea that's awesome to
show, go talk to
this sponsors.
Ask them, see if they think it's
a good idea, and then ask
for pointers.
How can you guess that and
which functions you code.
Take shortcuts.
The sponsors are there
to help you.
Another shortcut that you can
take is only implement the
thing that you are
going to demo.
I mean sure, go ahead and build
up the whole screen with
five buttons, but just make one
button work and demo that
button onscreen.
And very importantly,
seek help.
Give yourself at most a minute
if you are stuck.
And then ask.
Ask somebody.
You can ask the sponsors, but
you can ask people around you.
Yes, it's a competition, but
the spirit is to help each
other so just go ahead and ask
and help others as well.
Remember focus, focus, focus.
Yes you're helping other people
but think about what
are you going to demo
and focus on that.
Work on that.
And one tip that I would give
is make sure that you have a
one-hour alarm right
before the demo.
At that point it's a
real code freeze.
You are not touching
that code base.
At that point you need to
rehearse your demo, make sure
that your projector is hooked
up properly, so that you're
ready for showtime.
Then you can get on stage, show
that one feature, and
dazzle the crowd.
So if I may summarize the whole
thing in just one single
word, it's demo.
The whole day, think about what
you're going to demo,
focus on that, work backwards,
and you will win.
Thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER 2: What do you
think of when I say the word
chaos and chaos theory?
Is it a fantastic pickup
line for a scientist?
Maybe how crazy and complex
the weather is.
But here's the thing, every
single one of you already
knows about chaos theory.
Think for a moment about if
you were a quarter second
early or late to some critical
moment in your life.
How radically different
the world would be.
That idea's been around science
fiction, been around
books, but how did it
really come to be
in terms of a science?
Well it starts with this
fundamental question back in
the early 1800s.
Is Jupiter going to go careening
off into the moon?
Are we going to have the
sun go crazy on us?
Or the moon crash
into the Earth?
It was such a critical problem
that King Oscar II for his
60th birthday commissioned
the first Oscar.
And in that prize, he invited
all the mathematicians and
physicists to test out their
theories and ideas.
And 12 entered and three years
later one of them had a
magnificent 150 pages of
equations so they said, wow
it's so full equations,
you win.
And the biggest part of it was
he didn't solve the problem.
He said, well let me take the
Sun, the Earth, and the Moon
and see what happens.
But then a graduate student
came along.
And as the graduate student is
looking at it there's this
problem and they realize that
with the math this crazy stuff
could happen.
It was almost as if there was
chaotic trajectories.
And the problem would remain
this way for nearly 100 years
until Ed Lorenz would
come along.
And he was working on
atmospheric models and he put
these models into one of the
first computers and put in
something like 3.17825 as one
of the starting conditions.
And one day he decided he wanted
to get a coffee and
didn't want to enter that
so he put in 3.12.
And then when he looked at the
results it was the same for a
little while and then wildly,
wildly different.
So he took apart the computer,
tried to figure out what the
heck was wrong, see if there's
any real bugs or roaches
inside there, put it
back together,
the same thing happened.
And what he realized is that
the world with weather is
incredibly interconnected.
And this idea that a butterfly
flapping its wings in one part
of the world could cause
a tornado on the
other side was born.
And the problem, once again,
would stay this way because
nobody knew what
to do with it.
And it would stay this way for
10 years until Jim Yorke would
come along.
And Jim had two fantastic
things going for him.
The first is he titled his paper
"Period Three Implies
Chaos," thereby naming
the field.
The second is this new type of
device that could sit on top
of your desktop.
This, the personal computer.
Because now, for the very first
time, he could put in
those same equations Poincare
was working on, he could see
the behavior that Lorenz
was also seeing.
All this rich behavior, the
fractals, all that stuff that
was coming about.
And in fact, as they were
starting to dig into it they
realized that there were very,
very simple systems that would
come about.
Not like this table, but what's
underneath the table.
And this thing, which is this
very simple device which is
one of the first original ones
to describe chaos theory.
And you realize that you can
get incredibly complex
behavior out of such a very
simple, elementary system.
And as they realized and dug
into this it was all over the
place, all over the world
in math, weather.
All over things.
But as you get to this there
came a question.
Well, great, what are we
supposed to do with it?
How do we actually
think about it?
And so a remarkable experiment
happened in 1978.
A satellite was launched
on ISEE 3.
And it had all these whiz-bang
sensors and all this great
stuff on it.
But after a few years it was
running into a problem.
It had only two spray cans
worth of propellant left.
But the guy said, hey you know
what, we got this comet coming
at us, we've got all the right
sensors, we don't have time to
build a new satellite.
Why don't we try to
fly this through?
And the guy said, uh,
two spray cans.
That's all we got.
But wait, this is the same
problem Poincare did.
A big planet, a small planet,
and a tiny one.
So 37 controlled burns later
of spray paint, five lunar
fly-bys, getting as close as 80
miles to the surface of the
moon, they were able to not
fly through one comet but
through two comets using
controlled chaos.
Let's get back to the weather.
What can we say about chaos?
If we know that there's small
changes that lead to big
changes why run one
weather model?
We should run lots of
weather models.
In fact, that's what
we do today.
We run an ensemble of them and
where the forecasts line up,
we have a good forecast.
Where they don't line up,
we have a bad forecast.
For the first time this was
used in the early '80s to
predict one of the
major snowstorms
over the Eastern seaboard.
And what you can see over here
is all that kind of spaghetti
lining up over the East coast.
But you'll notice over
the Atlantic you've
got horrible forecasts.
And so when you listen to
weather these days and you
hear this and they say, well
we're going to watch this,
this is actually what
they're looking at.
And if I have to leave you with
one thing, what chaos
tells us is the world is
incredibly interconnected and
that interconnectedness is
really what drives the world
and, from a sci-fi angle to
now what you take as a
science, is something that
lives in everyday life.
Thank you.
CHRIS VEIN: And now,
as they say, for
something completely different.
I am Chris Vein, I'm the Deputy
United States Chief
Technology Officer and I'm here
to talk to you about open
innovation.
Open innovation.
What we're really talking about
is how we're opening up
government, making it more
participative, collaborative,
and enabling folks like you
to help us solve problems.
I think that I have the coolest
job in Washington
because I get to travel around
the country, if not around the
world, really looking at
what's happening in an
innovation space, in the private
sector, public sector,
and extract kind of the secret
sauce, the stuff that makes it
all worthwhile.
Actually, he's got the
coolest job in
Washington, especially today.
But let me tell you, that the
president understands that the
problems we face are
just too great.
We don't have time
to use the usual
ways of solving problems.
We have to innovate, we have
to use technology.
Let me tell you about
three problems.
The first is that the population
of the United
States and the world
is approaching 9.3
billion people in 2050.
And May 23, 2007, that's
when the world became
the majority urban.
And in the next two decades
we're going to be
even 2/3 to 3/4 urban.
The last stat that I've
got for you is 12%.
That's the arable land left in
the planet that we can use to
plant crops.
So what this all means is that
we have to double down, we
have to use technology, and
figure out how we're going to
make our current land more
efficient in order to feed all
those people.
That's why the president says,
and he said this to me many
times, we need to think about
how technology can be used to
solve these problems and we need
to think about that every
second of every day in
order to do that.
Blank screen.
There we go.
When I was Chief Information
Officer for the city and
county of San Francisco, I often
worked on this problem
of, how do we reduce
bureaucratic barriers?
What could happen if government
actually got out of
the way and allowed citizens and
hackers and everybody to
really work on solving
problems?
This is what we've done with the
Data.gov platform and I'm
going to be talking about
data from now on.
We've actually open sourced the
Data.gov platform and made
it worldwide in its
applicability.
Imagine if we had data from
cities and counties and states
and tribes and governments
around the world all on the
same platform.
Imagine what we could do with
that data, the problems that
we could solve.
And it's not something that
we haven't tried before.
Decades ago, NOAA released all
of the data around weather and
the weather industry
was created.
The defense department did the
same thing with GPS and now
we've got GPS everywhere.
That all came from
the government.
So let me tell you about four
current examples of what we're
doing with Blue Button.
We are allowing vets to download
their personal health
care record and take that
personal health care record
wherever they go.
And when it comes to energy,
we're doing the same thing but
we're working with the
private sector.
And we're getting energy
companies to let citizens
download their personal data so
that they can make better
purchasing decisions.
When it comes to education, a
big topic these days, we're
doing the same thing.
We're allowing folks to
start downloading
their financial data.
We're looking at releasing all
of the new tools around
learning registries and all of
the educational data to help
citizens make better-informed
decisions.
The last example I want to
talk about is safety.
Tens of thousands of
people die every
year in traffic accidents.
Imagine, if we could get the
data out of every vehicle
that's involved in every one of
those traffic accidents and
extract it, what we could do.
It's a model that's working and
what I want to tell you is
what we're doing is we're
taking groups of people,
bringing them to Washington,
we're focusing on solving
problems in 90 days, and we're
releasing the solutions.
It's that minimum viable
product that
Eric Ries talks about.
And one of the ways that we've
actually put this on steroids
is to develop the Presidential
Innovation Fellows Program
where we're actually letting
people sign up to come to
Washington and help
us work and solve
some of these problems.
But we know that that's
not enough.
We know that we need to make
some structural changes in how
the federal government works.
We need to create government
as a platform.
We need to make everything API
and we need to make our data
automatically released.
So here's my pitch.
My pitch is that we need you,
we're working with you, and
we're creating opportunities for
you to work with us from
Washington to where
you sit every day.
As we release all of our
projects, and our data, and
our APIs, we ask
you to help us.
Come work with us and create
the next generation of
government.
Thank you.
JOHN VLACHOYIANNIS:
[SPEAKING GREEK], San Francisco?
I'm John, I'm from Greece.
And I'm going to talk to you
about music, data and how
actually we geeks
are rockstars.
You have less than five seconds,
I believe, to follow
my Twitter.
Do it right now.
So we don't really know
the origins of music.
Scientists believe that we
started creating music the
moment we started to
imitate nature.
I believe that we actually
haven't created any music if
you're listening to
Justin Bieber.
But whatever.
So as I said previously
I'm from Greece.
So we Greeks, I won't say that
we created music, but where
music comes from, muses.
Muse is actually the word
for Goddesses of art, of
inspiration, everything.
So we Greeks tried to
correlate music and
mathematics a long time ago.
This guy Pythagoras, let
me tell you a little
bit about this guy.
This guy was so obsessed
with fractions.
So one time he was passing
through an anvil store.
He realized that the size of the
anvil determines how the
sound actually--
you can hear the sound.
And that's how the diatonic
scale, the twelve notes we
have today were created.
Now moving a little bit forward
in time, we realized
that actually tones, music
tones, are actually sound
waves and we can manipulate
their attitude and tones and
everything.
So of course, geeks
took control.
And realized that we can create
programs where we can
manipulate sounds on the fly,
creating electronic music and
everything and interesting
stuff.
Actually if you guys were here
at Google I/O last year,
SexyVisuals, which were
from Pixar, Lucas
Arts, Apple, and Google--
there were some guys that were
creating music, live
programming music on the fly.
Yeah and audio and vision was
pretty, pretty, pretty good.
You should check them out.
So I'll tell you about
my personal epiphany.
My personal epiphany came the
moment I realized that
actually music is nothing
more than data.
And code is data so data is
music and all this stuff.
So we started and implemented,
like a
proper geek, a language.
A programming language where it
enables you to write music
in real time.
The language called MAD, it's
based on LISP and it's using
the processing framework.
It's the best framework
for audio and visual.
So combining all this we'll
have some time.
So here's the specification.
We just play a pattern and
the pattern is a kick.
So when you execute this
one you have [THUMP].
[INAUDIBLE].
So by executing this, the kick
is data but it also is music.
Doesn't sound so much
right now, but
give me a couple seconds.
So now we are adding kick,
high hat, and tom.
So if we play this pattern,
you have it
[MAKING DRUM SOUNDS].
All together, don't be afraid.
Come on, come on guys.
So let's try something
more difficult.
Now let's say that we would
define a pattern that's
actually musical note.
The first example plays
the [SINGING].
A pretty easy scale.
But if we apply data
transformation, the reverse,
[INAUDIBLE]
we get the [SINGING].
And of course we can start with
writing some interesting
cues like the [SINGING].
This is the Tron soundtrack.
And it's pretty easy to--
okay, it's not that easy.
But you can see that actually
music is data.
And of course, of course, if
you are fans of dubstep you
can apply these functions and
you have the [MAKING SOUNDS]
and all this strange
stuff that dubstep
is all about today.
But imagine, music
is actually data.
So when I released the language,
a guy came and told
me, okay, but can you Bach?
I told him, come on man,
I'm just a geek, I
can't do that stuff.
So this guy went a little
bit crazy so he started
implementing all this in my
programming language.
And this is exactly
the same thing.
And this is the right hand,
he's also written the left
hand, and he's playing all of
them in unison and all of this
crazy stuff.
And once in a while, he emails
me videos of him playing Bach
and he's in his house.
He's a crazy guy.
So actually data is
music, right.
So what if I get the latest
tweets, I convert them to
notes, and play them?
Guys, you won't believe that.
This actually makes sense.
If you go [INAUDIBLE] on this
on the site, on MAD's site,
you'll see in a couple of
slides, actually makes sense.
It's unbelievable.
So I was using processing
framework, I told you a couple
of minutes ago.
You could use Overtones,
another framework
again built on LISP.
And of course you could use
ClojureScript so you can run
everything on your browser.
You could create this music
on your browser.
So let's disrupt, a
little bit, music.
So imagine that all albums
are Github, right.
So you could clone them, fork
them, make modifications in
the [? bag. ?]
And also, you have revisions,
you could share music as code.
That disrupts everything.
So we're building a band.
Of course we're geeks, we wanna
be rock stars, so we're
building a band.
If you're Skrillex or someone
else, please join us at--
again my Twitter, follow
it right now guys.
And let's rock.
Thank you, everybody.
Have fun.
THOMAS PARK: We live in a
world full of questions.
Deep, philosophical questions
like if I bike to work
tomorrow, will it rain
on me on my way home?
What's GOOG's sticker price
going to be next week?
And that cute brunette over
there, will she be into you
given the information on
your public profiles?
So I'm Thomas Park, I
work for Google in
Seattle on cloud computing.
Before that I worked at a
bunch of other places.
And tonight we're going to
talk about solving these
problems using technology.
But before that, I'd like to
make sure that we're all on
the same page with regards
to analytical modeling.
So quick overview, you ready?
Here we've got a
bunch of data.
It's two data classes,
red and blue.
If we want to build a model
describing this data, we'll
take about 70% of it, call it
the training set, draw a line
along the geometric median such
that blue's on one side,
red's on the side
for most part.
Then we can evaluate the
performance of this model by
putting the data points in the
rest of the data set through
the model and comparing
the red-blue result
with the known result.
Pretty simple.
So now that we know all about
analytical modeling, phew,
let's talk about machine
learning.
So this is the application of
algorithms to find interesting
patterns in groups and data,.
Such as, for example, if we look
at the shape, color, and
texture of these mushrooms,
will they be delicious,
poisonous, or make me
see funny colors?
So let's turn up the
heat a little bit.
Let's say that Google
is launching dating
functionality.
We're going to use the
information in your G+ profile
to find interesting people
for you to meet.
Now there's a clear vector
for abuse here.
You can create a lot of
profiles with a lot of
interests and get a
lot of hookups.
So maybe the G+ team wants to
use machine learning to detect
whether or not a user creating
an account is a bot.
We can use variables
like this.
Now one of the interesting
things about machine learning
is that it still requires
human intuition.
It's easy for you and I look at
these and see that one of
these is not a very plausible
email address.
So we need to extract
features from these.
Such as, do Google hit results
exist from the name, and are
the letter sequences possible?
So now I want to talk to
you about something
called random forest.
Please raise your hand if you're
familiar with these.
Now it's a pretty powerful
technique, it's been around
for about 15, 20 years but
almost nobody's heard of it.
So I'll spend the
rest of my talk
focusing on random forest.
What are these in a nutshell?
The idea is that instead of
building a really great model,
we're going to build a large
number of crappy models kind
of like a red-blue
[? pacifier. ?]
We'll let them vote and then
take the aggregate or the
average across all the models
and then that'll give us
actually pretty good behavior.
So how does this look
in practice?
We're going to use a large
number of variables, ideally
much more than what I have here,
and build decision trees
that fit this model exactly.
Each of the decision trees is
going to use a small random
subset of the data.
That's the random in
random forest.
Why is this interesting?
So what we'll see is that we're
building models that
work OK for a lot of data but
in some cases, since we're
building these models from
reserve data, we'll have
variables that are very
predictive and so they work
really, really well.
Except for when our users'
script decides to stop
advertising it's user agent
as libwww-perl.
So now the performance in
model one has tanked.
But in an ideal situation, we'd
have enough models that
still perform well that will
get good overall results.
Now in a real world situation
we'd be using a very large
number of these trees, hundreds
more, each using
maybe five to ten variables.
It's interesting to note also
that these trees are totally
independent.
We can grow them and evaluate
them in parallel.
Not all machine learning
algorithms can do this.
That's cool.
Now let's talk a little bit
more about variables.
Most of these require human
intuition, like I said.
But random forest will help
us out there as well.
You also notice that we're not
using variables with a huge
value space like IP
address, raw IP.
There's just too many values
to it, too much noise.
So in a situation like this we
can use something called
binning, where we separate the
data into categories that make
more sense.
If you guys have answered
surveys that ask your age
it'll often say under 18,
18 to 24, et cetera.
Now when we're feeding data to
the trees, one of the cool
things about the random forest
algorithm is that it can
actually tell us what variables
are predictive.
So we can feed it a lot of
data without necessarily
caring too much about whether
or not it's a good variable.
So we've been talking mostly
about using random forest as a
classifier, a binary
classifier.
Is bot, is not bot.
But it can also be
used to recognize
interesting groups of data.
Which in our dating case
might be interesting
people for you to meet.
So 15 seconds less, how
does this work?
When we are running data through
our models, we're
going to see what terminal
node, what leaf
node it winds up in.
All of the data goes through
all of the trees, so we can
keep track of how often two
data points wind up in the
same terminal state.
And that'll tell us how
similar the data is.
So hopefully I've piqued your
interest about machine
learning and random
forest there.
I'd just like to thank Ignite
for bringing me on to talk.
And thank you to all the artists
who've put your photos
out there under Creative
Commons.
Thank you.
CHRISTOPHER MARKS: It was late
on a summer night as I sat
typing "Your offer is too low,"
into Google Translate to
sell my 10 gallon hat with the
scorching flames particle
effect to a Japanese man
that I wondered,
how did I get here?
This is my story.
When I was a noob, my friend Joe
told me to kill cows and
lumber so I could train my
combat and sell the hides for
100 GP each at the local bank.
I thought I was going to be the
richest player in RuneScape.
I set off to collect
10 million of them.
But when I got to the bank I saw
someone was selling them
there for 50 GP each.
At first I thought I was going
to lose all of my profit as I
had been undercut.
But then I realized that I could
buy his hides for 50 GP
each and then sell them
for 100 GP each and
make a quick profit.
And this was incredible to
10-year-old me because I
realized that I could make
money by not actually
gathering materials but
by simply buying
low and selling high.
And this is the what got
me into trading.
Later on I was on a quest and
I noticed an NPC that sold
dragon daggers for 17k each
which I could poison for 1k
each and then hop to a PVP world
and sell for 55k each.
And this was an incredible
profit for little effort.
RuneScape implemented a Grand
Exchange which allowed players
to not just shout outside of
banks but go to a building and
sell their items and have trades
match up automatically.
And have prices change
according
to supply and demand.
And with this came Grand
Exchange price graphs, which I
analyzed to see that when items
were at their lower
price I would buy them up
and cause the price to
artificially rise to turn
a quick profit.
And this idea eventually led to
clan merchanting which was
essentially the same thing but
involved a larger group of
people to buy more items.
However be higher-up members of
the clan would usually sell
their items before the other
people and would cause people
to lose most of their profits.
Now RuneScape imposed a trade
limit which was a maximum of
60k in order to stop scamming
and real-world trading.
But to get around this traders
would add junk items, which
had a market price value but
no actual real value, to
change the price of the items.
Flipping is essentially over
bidding on an item and then
under bidding on an item
to find its price.
Then you buy the item for one
GP over the lower bound and
then sell it for one GP under
the higher bound so you can
undercut everybody and
make a quick profit.
Now there are two main types of
items in RuneScape, there's
useful and there's cosmetic.
However of course there are
higher-level armors which cost
a lot of money because they are
useful, so they fall into
that category.
But there are a set of items
which are the most important
cosmetic items because
they're discontinued.
And since they aren't going to
be released into the game
anymore they're only going to
rise in the long term even if
they drop in the short term.
As well as players getting
enough money to buy them,
increasing the demand
of the item.
Now there are items like this
that are not only in RuneScape
but in Team Fortress 2.
And the currency in RuneScape
is set in stone because they
have gold coins.
But in Team Fortress 2 it's much
more based on arbitrage
which changes it quite a bit.
So in Team Fortress 2 there's
metal keys and buds which are
the primary currency.
Buds were a promotional item
released by Valve when Team
Fortress 2 was released for Mac
and they are the preferred
currency to be paid
in unusuals.
And there are four main
ways to make money
when trading unusuals.
The first is to buy buds for
$31, then sell them for 24
keys, then sell the keys for
$1.49 each and make $4.76 per
bud that you sell.
And it may not seem like a lot
but it adds up pretty quickly.
The second way is unusual
trading, which is what I did.
And it would take forever to
explain it but basically you
buy the hats that have a good
effect and that have the good
class as well as the specific
hats that people want.
But the main trick when dealing
with unusual trading
is to find people who actually
want the hats and
to be nice to them.
Because being an asshole loses
you 99% of your trades.
The third way that people make
money is by idling, by setting
up 10 or so accounts to collect
the five to seven
items that Valve releases
per week.
And they would use the items
they gather to sell them to
get metal to buy the hats and
stuff that they wanted.
And the fourth way that people
would make money, which is
obviously the most frowned upon,
is by finding people who
don't know what their
hats are worth.
So it's essentially finding
someone and scanning them for
their hat which you can sell
for between $20 to $1,500.
And recently Valve hired an
economist whose name is Yanis
Varoufakis and he's been
analyzing the economy from a
real-life perspective by
looking at equilibrium.
And so far he has most
of it right but he's
still a bit of a noob.
Thank you.
DAVID WEEKLY: Hey everybody.
I'm David Weekly.
A number of years ago I was 25
living in a city and looking
for ways to throw
awesome parties.
So I did what any reasonable
young gentleman would do and I
started finding some housemates
that I could go and
split a crazy mansion with
in Hillsborough.
We decided to call it Super
Happy Fun House after the
Happy Fun Ball from Saturday
Night Live.
And we resolved to go and
throw crazy parties.
So our very first party that
we had, we had about 150
people including a California
gubernatorial candidate who I
briefly ended up dating
and a film crew.
And so it was pretty clear we
were on to something, we
should do it again.
So we started throwing these
parties once every six weeks.
We had professional DJs, we had
two story high banners to
welcome people there, we
had in-ground hot tubs.
It was a lot of fun.
Two of my roommates worked at
IDO so we had all kinds of
custom built stuff.
Like a freezer we custom
converted into a photobooth.
That's Aaron Patzer
from Mint.com.
We even went ahead and built a
custom dance cage that people
would go and dance in.
These parties were great.
And they became very,
very popular.
So popular that by the time we
got to the ninth one of these
parties more than 400 people
showed up, they'd cordoned off
the surrounding two blocks, they
had put the SWAT team on
high alert, and we
got into trouble.
So they cops said, you need to
stop throwing these parties.
They wrote the landlord
a pretty angry letter.
So we were bummed out.
We were thinking, these
parties were great.
They actually contributed to
the fabric of society.
People are getting to meet each
other and connect with
each other in meaningful
ways, right?
There were actually six couples
who met at these
parties who ended up
getting married.
So what can we do to bring
people together that's not
going to get the cops
called on us again?
So one of my really nerdy
friends proposed something
really interesting.
He had been part of a LAN party
scene down in Los Gatos
and he suggested that we do
something that's like a LAN
party but it's productive
instead.
It's LANing plus Deving.
So it's a party, a LAN party,
and its productive.
So we'd have beer and
Red Bull and fast
internet and all that.
So we had the very first
SuperHappyDevHouse in mid 2005
and we got about 15 people to go
and show up between 7:00 PM
and 7:00 AM and it was
a tremendous success.
I ended up coding the first
version of PBwiki, which ended
up becoming a real company,
between 1:00
and 8:00 in the morning.
And so we said let's do this
every six weeks and we did.
And it got bigger and bigger
and bigger just like Super
Happy Fun House did and by the
time we had done nine of them
at my house my roommates got
really sick of a couple
hundred nerds going in
taking over the house
all day on a Saturday.
So we started rotating where
we had them and then by the
time we got to the 30th DevHouse
at Sun's Executive
Briefing Center, which is
now Facebook's global
headquarters, we had people
overflowing this facility.
And I said, you know what
I would hate to do at
the end of the night?
I would hate to go and
kick you all out.
But I'm going to need to,
because otherwise Sun security
is going to get mad at me.
So what if there was a
place where I didn't
need to kick you out?
We could call it Hacker Dojo.
And this could be a place that
was open 24/7 for you to build
whatever the hell you want to.
You could wake up at 3:00 in
the morning and be like, I
want to go and build
something cool.
We'd have fast internet and
tables and chairs and not a
whole lot else more.
So after about six months of
figuring it out and getting an
initial membership base we
opened Hacker Dojo at 140A
South Whisman in
Mountain View.
I encourage you to come visit.
It's open 24/7.
We started getting
more and more
membership at $100 a month.
We were able to very quickly
make ends meet.
We've leased out more and more
parts of the building until
now today we're the largest
hacker space in the world.
We've rented out the entire
building, some
13,000 square feet.
There are some minor
difficulties we're still
undergoing with the city in
terms of a quarter million
dollars of renovations that we
need to make to fire safety
and all that.
So your contribution would
be appreciated.
But come on by, drop on by.
Pinterest was actually started
at Hacker Dojo.
Dozens of companies have
started there.
It's just a tremendous
community resource.
What about SuperHappyDevHouse?
We recently celebrated the
50th SuperHappyDevHouse.
A Super Happy block party
was advertised by the
mayor of Palo Alto.
About 2,000 people showed up.
We cordoned off a whole
block of Palo Alto.
It was tremendous just to see
those many people building.
DevHouse has also
been replicated
all around the planet.
I just came back from Singapore
where they were
doing one of their
DevHouses there.
They're have been dozens of
DevHouses down in Mexico.
They're pretty easy to throw.
You just get a bunch of people
together and you hack all
night long.
It doesn't have to have a
winner, doesn't have to be a
competition.
DevHouse has also inspired other
DevHouse-like events,
things like BarCamp that's been
all around the world.
Corporate hackathons
like Facebook.
And here we see a bunch of kids
going and doing a hackathon.
Hack the Future is what
that's called.
So getting kids involved in
coding and production.
These things are really
important.
Because they inspire folks,
they get folks started.
Woz actually was first
introduced to a computer at a
very early hackathon some 30
years ago at the Homebrew
Computer Club.
That's where he got introduced
to his first computer.
So you can do this.
Go build a hackathon.
Get a dozen people
together in your
room and go copy DevHouse.
Thank you.
RICHARD WARP: Good evening.
Everybody here, I'm sure,
has a question
that they dread answering.
Whether it's at a conference
or a party or a friend's
wedding, it comes at you from
nowhere and there's nothing
you can do about it.
So for me that question
is, what do you do?
So the conversation would
go something like this.
What you do?
I'm a composer.
Oh, what do you play?
I don't really play
an instrument.
OK so what kind of
songs you write?
Well I don't really
write songs.
OK so what kind of music
do yo write then?
Well I'm not sure I'd really
call it music.
Interesting.
I'm just going to go
and get a drink.
So the conversation doesn't
always have to go like that
but generally speaking, if you
want to have a nice quiet time
at a party, tell them you're
an avant-garde composer.
So avant-garde composers have
historically had this image of
themselves as being on the
leading edge of musical
frontiers and breaking
down barriers.
Sticking it to the man, all
this kind of thing.
But audiences, at least these
days, have a sort of slightly
different idea of avant-garde
composers as definitely less
than heroic.
And that's a shame because
there's a huge amount of
really great experimental music
out there but the stigma
sort of still remains.
So why is that?
Well if we rewind a couple
hundred years, if you want to
hear new music you'd
go to a concert.
It was all about concerts, and
audiences, and premiers.
But as soon as recording
technology came around-- and I
love recording technology,
by the way--
composers could then experiment
till the cows come
home and there were studios and
they didn't have to show
it for an audience.
So studios became like
laboratories.
But the problem was that
composers thought they could
take that stuff out on the road
and it didn't go down so
well with public.
So against that backdrop of
experimental music, I'm going
to share a few of my experiences
with you.
So I've been very interested,
the last couple of years, in
the relationship between
music and the brain.
So my wife's a neuroscientist,
my drinking buddy's a
neuroscientist, there's just
brains all over the place.
So I got to asking, well what
can we do with this?
So I started working with the
EEG signal and neurofeedback
and started developing with some
neuroscientist friends
what's called a BCMI, or Brain
Computer Music Interface.
EEG is great.
It's cheap, it's non-invasive,
it looks cool.
And so we started working on
an installation that we got
approached to do involving
the internet.
And we came up with this
idea of redoing a
classic piece from 1965.
We called ours, Music for
Online Performer.
So what we did was we streamed
the live brain signal, split
between the four frequency
bands, over the web via open
sound control to the UK into a
concert space which was hooked
up to an Arduino interface that
controlled robots that
would play acoustic instruments
in real time.
We also had a live stream chat
room going on where people
could log in, they
could comment.
We even took requests.
It was like, more drum.
OK, increase beta power.
It was a complex dynamic
system which is kind of
multi-level with social
interaction and robots on the
other side of the planet.
So how did it sound?
Well I have to tell you, it
sounded pretty terrible.
It really didn't sound
that good.
And that wasn't the point.
The point was that we wanted to
show that we could connect
all this stuff together and
that it could work over an
hour long performance with
various different time zones.
But at the end of the day,
this was a music concert.
And our robots ended up sounding
like that candy
making machine out of Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory.
So it was great proof of concept
but as a piece of
music maybe not so great.
So we as artists, I think,
want to get from proof of
concept to what I would
call proof of context.
So what do I mean by that?
Basically that you as the
audience shouldn't have to
bring the context
in which you.
You shouldn't have to have read
a book on experimental
music in order to be able to
kind of appreciate the output.
So in our case, the context
was a quartet of robots.
Now in a real quartet the
instrumentalists listen to
each other and they kind of put
it all together and they
vibe off each other.
So if we had just tweaked the
algorithm a little it so that
the signals were listening to
each other and not all playing
at the same time it would
have had a better
sort of musical context.
So just to demonstrate the
power context little
bit, this is Bob.
He's a theremin.
And he's two oscillators
heterodyning and you probably
recognize the sound.
It's kind of this sort of
sci-fi, kind of annoying sound
after a while.
But if we just tweak the
algorithm ever so slightly by
applying some musical rules
we can have a very
different kind of sound.
Bob has a lovely singing
voice now.
At least to my Western ears.
So that's what I would
call context.
And in terms of what we're doing
to do contextual music
in the future, we're working
on a project for next May
which will take music
as emotion.
And we're looking to output that
in a more contextual way.
So next time you see me, you
ask me what I do, I'll
hopefully be able to say, I'm
glad you asked me that, let's
get a drink.
Thanks very much.
AMY JO KIM: Hi, I'm Amy
Jo Kim and I have a
confession to make.
Although I design rating systems
for a living, I hate
competing with other people.
What I love is collaborative
gaming.
I love working together to
create something bigger than
we could do on our own.
When I first started working in
the games industry gaming
meant competition.
Here's a textbook example, a
system where players engage in
a conflict with rules and
a quantifiable outcome.
Well that certainly describes
some kind of games.
Game theory can help
us with this.
It defines zero-sum games.
Games where there's a
winner and a loser.
We're opponents.
These kind of games are what
most people think of when they
think of games.
Good examples are any
war simulation.
Chess, Go, Polo.
Head to head battles,
rank-ordered competitions,
gambling, where you're playing
either against other players
or against the house, these
are all zero-sum games.
What I found as I worked in the
games industry was that
the games I was working on and
loved didn't fall neatly into
this definition.
Ultima Online, The
Sims, Rock Band.
All of them were structured
more around having fun
together and not around
pummeling your opponents.
So I tried to invent a different
definition and I
slowly realized what these were,
were non-zero-sum games.
Games where rather than
opponents, we're partners.
We win together and
we lose together.
Some examples are double dutch
on the playground, Pictionary
and other party games, martial
arts like karate where you
have social support for your
personal progress, any charity
walk or event, these are
all non-zero-sum games.
And the reason that you should
care about this is because the
games industry is undergoing
massive disruption.
And that's creating big
new opportunities for
collaborative games and
services, particularly those
the target females.
Three trends are driving this.
The first trend is ubiquitous
connected devices.
Games used to be played
on consoles.
But the shift to smartphones
and tablets and mobile
computing has disrupted this.
That's where the
action is now.
That's where people are looking
to play their games.
And that's where they're
spending more money.
If you look at the overall games
industry shown here, the
overall industry's growing
but at the bottom
there that's consoles.
Flat, it's even declining.
All the growth is coming
from mobile and online.
It's not just living
room consoles
that are being disrupted.
Portable gaming.
Here you have a slide that
basically shows portable
gaming consoles' lunch being
eaten by iOS and Android.
These mobile computing devices
are where people are more and
more playing games and they are
bringing in a different
and more mainstream audience.
That's the second trend.
Gamers are mainstream
and all-ages.
Gaming has matured
into a mainstream
entertainment medium.
And the audience, which is
gender balanced and many ages,
reflects that.
Did you know, for instance,
that the fastest growing
demographic on Facebook
is women 55 plus?
And that 93% of kids 8 to 13
play games online and they
cite Facebook as the main
place they do it.
What's happening is people are
playing games and they're also
getting on social media,
staying up to
date, sharing photos.
Which leads us to the third
disruptive trend.
Mutual entertainment.
More and more people are engaged
in sharing content
they and their friends
have created.
That's sucking time away from
highly crafted experiences
like traditional games.
Look at the hours people
are spending.
Here what you see is
games are popular.
Absolutely very popular, but
those hours are dwarfed by the
hours people are spending on
sites like Facebook, YouTube,
and Twitter.
If you look at Instagram, it's a
great example of this mutual
entertainment trend.
It's a photo sharing app.
It's got this addictive loop
where you don't know what's
coming next and the likes and
comments from friends give you
a pleasing but unpredictable
feedback loop.
Draw Something is another
great example.
You play with a friend, if you
draw the right word, they
guess it correctly
you both win.
If they don't guess
it, you both lose.
Its non-zero-sum.
Great example of mutual
entertainment.
Now we know from recent studies
in happiness that a
way to make yourself reliably
unhappier is to do social
comparison.
It's also very motivating which
is why everyone wants a
leaderboard on their website
even when it's a
really stupid idea.
We also know from happiness
studies that investing in
social relationships
will reliably
lead you to be happier.
Collaborative games
can deliver this.
It's a blue ocean market with
a big audience of gamers.
Male and female, smartphones
in hand, waiting for games
that they can play together that
will bring them together.
There's a Zulu word Ubuntu
that captures this
non-zero-sum mentality.
So the next time you're doing
any project, gamification,
games, think collaboration
first.
See where it takes you.
Thank you.
PETER NORVIG: Hi.
I'm Peter Norvig.
And I taught a class too 100,000
students at a time.
I started this off because I
had written a traditional
textbook, a textbook on
artificial intelligence, and
we were happy that my co-author
and I were able to
capture over 90% of the
market for textbooks.
And so that was great.
But the experience of writing
a textbook felt so limiting
because everything was stamped
on paper, or you can now get
an electronic version,
it's stamped on PDF.
And it's static.
And I knew people were
interacting with it in a
non-static way.
They were underlining the
parts that they liked.
They were underlining in a
different color the parts that
were confusing.
They were bookmarking the
important places.
That was all happening and I
wasn't capturing any of that
so I want to get it back.
Also there were complex things
like these charts that I
created with data that I
manipulated with a program.
I learned a lot from that
manipulation and then all they
see is the static paper.
So I wanted to go beyond that.
I wanted to give them that
hands-on experience.
So my co-teacher, Sebastian
Thrun, and I said, we're going
to do that.
We're going to bring an
interactive experience, more
interactive than a textbook, and
we're going to bring it to
more people.
We're going to bring it to
thousands of people at a time.
We didn't know how many
we were going to get.
But it turned out the answer was
160,000 people signed up.
By the end of the class of
80,000 were 7 day actives and
23,000 finished all the
homework, did the equivalent
of a complete Stanford class.
Now how do we deliver that?
Well we learned from Benjamin
Bloom that one-on-one
mentoring delivers teaching
that's two standard deviations
above the norm.
So you deliver a regular class
and compare that to
one-on-one, you get two standard
deviations better.
So we wanted to emulate that
one-on-one experience.
We saw Sal Khan had done a great
job with short videos.
That short, 10 minute videos
are better than
an hour long one.
We want to go even shorter.
So we went one or two
minutes and then
interspersed the questions.
And it was ironic, I think,
that in trying to disrupt
regular education we ended up
being more like a traditional
education, a traditional
college.
Because we found that what's
most important is the social
experience.
Interacting with each other,
not interacting with the
online components.
And these are some of the social
networking sites that
the students use and sort of
spontaneously developed.
They went out and used all these
online tools so they can
interact with each other.
The thing I learned the most
from was Teach For America.
Where I learned about teachers
who did an amazing job taking
students who were two years
behind grade level and in one
year they brought them all
up to where they belong.
Now this was a shock to me
because I worked at Google for
many years and I thought what
my role was, is you take a
hard question like that and
you do all this tough
algorithmic stuff and then
you get the right answer.
And I was proud that we can
do that kind of thing.
But then I realized,
wait a minute.
Getting the right answer,
that's the easy part.
The hard part is asking
the questions.
Getting people motivated so that
they want to engage and
ask questions.
Now finally, this is a
college transcript.
It transmits about 48 bits
of information per year.
This is an iPod.
It translates about 192,000
bits per second.
So that's a trillion
times more.
By cost, it's a quadrillion
We can get more data by
interacting online.
We can duplicate this one-on-one
experience, we can
bring it to 100,000 students,
but the real power is them
interacting with each other.
These 100,000 squared pairs
of students working
together in a community.
MIKE TYKA: Hi.
My name is Mike and I want
to talk to you about the
invention of the wheel.
As engineers, I think you will
appreciate that if you look to
nature, you're humbled
essentially.
Nature has come up with
helicopters and submarines and
color screens and high speed
cameras and all that stuff.
But one invention, to me,
that is typically
human is the wheel.
We have used wheels since the
beginning of our civilization
and they've really driven
a lot of the
progress we've made.
And we've made them small,
we've made them big.
Especially in the production
of energy.
For example, this one is 30
feet across and produces
electricity for millions
of people in China.
So the question I asked was, OK
so how does nature produce
its energy?
And to find out, we need
to look at some cells.
This is, for example, these are
protrusions from cells in
your ear that allow me
to hear me right now.
So let's take for example
a muscle cell.
Cut it open, look at it with
an electron microscope.
And so on the right, there's
the nucleus of the cell.
The fibers at the top are the
actual muscle fibers.
And then the green blobs are
mitochondria where all the
energy gets produced.
And you only have to eat food,
you breathe oxygen, and you
exhale carbon dioxide.
And of course there are no
fires inside your body.
Instead what happens is that
your body breaks down that
reaction into small steps
using enzymes.
And in each step the energy
released by the oxidation is
coupled to the production of
a molecule called ATP.
And that molecule, which will
come up in a minute, acts like
a battery, like a common
currency of the body.
You can charge it and you can
discharge it somewhere else
and use the energy to
do whatever you need
to do in the body.
Let's see, where are
we going from here?
Right.
OK, enzymes.
Enzymes are proteins.
Proteins are molecules that are
very large that are made
from small molecules
called amino acids.
And these are strung together
basically in a linear fashion,
just like there.
And then they fold up in these
very complicated shapes that
are determined by the sequence
of amino acids
that were put together.
And so the previous picture
is very complicated.
If I redraw it like this you can
sort of see how the chain
sort of folds up in is very,
very interesting shape.
And that was a very
small protein.
Typically proteins are much,
much larger like that one.
But the same principles apply.
There's a sequence that
determines the structure of
the protein and the structure
determines what it does.
How does the cell know which
order to put these together?
It basically reads
them off the DNA.
That is in fact what
DNA does, mostly.
So it reads off the sequence,
it makes the protein,
and it folds up.
How the sequence determines the
structure is actually one
of the big unknown,
unpredictable phenomenon of
biochemistry.
It is very computationally
intensive.
And actually at Google here,
we've done a bunch of stuff on
G-compute to try and get
around that problem.
OK, so back to bent
mitochondria.
So when you burn food, what
happens is that all of these
different reactions pump protons
into a space between
two membranes in these
mitochondria.
So it doesn't matter what
reaction it is, it all ends up
in this common currency
of proton pressure.
And then what happens is that
pressure that gets built up,
flows out of this interstitial
membrane space through this
molecule there.
And that's a very big protein
that people have examined and
it wasn't clear for a
while how it works.
We knew that the protons were
leaving on the bottom, they
were going through the membrane,
and somehow this was
powered to the production
of ATP at
the top of this molecule.
And how this coupling worked was
not clear until a bunch of
Japanese researchers did this
really cool experiment.
They drove the engine backwards,
attached it to a
glass slide, and then attached a
fiber at the top that is big
enough that you can
actually see it.
Remember this is a
single molecule.
And what they saw when they
looked down an optical
microscope was this.
This is actually the actual
data from the paper.
It basically rotates.
It moves the fiber around
in a circle.
And there's a single molecule
sitting at that axis.
So more work basically showed
that what is in fact happening
is that this is a tiny,
tiny turbine.
The protons flow out through the
membrane and they make the
bottom of the molecule rotate
and the rotation mechanically
couples the energy to the
production of this chemical
molecule, sort of charging
it with energy.
And the way that works is
essentially the camshaft
inside of that molecule--
once the molecule is bound
and has reacted,
the molecule is stuck.
And so the camshaft pushes up
the molecule so that it frees
up the binding site for
the next molecule.
So in conclusion--
oh, I should say if you look at
hand right now, there are
literally trillions
of these turbines
whirring away right now.
And I'm afraid to say, we're
pretty late with the invention
of the wheel.
About 3.5 billion years.
Thanks.
BRADY FORREST: All right, thank
you all for staying.
Thank you to our speakers.
Let's give them a hand.
And as I mentioned, there are
Ignites around the world so
definitely support your local
chapter or just start one.
You can contact me
about that later.
I'm Brady on Twitter.
Take care.